I have to tell you about something
interesting that's happened in the last
48 hours I received a bunch of emails
and tweets from people saying you know
David I wasn't planning to vote for
Biden because he's not a progressive I
don't believe in choosing the lesser of
two evils but after Donald Trump's
authoritarian nightmare of a declaration
on Monday night about deploying the
military to States I realize I have to
vote for Joe Biden this these last 72 or
so hours from Donald Trump for many of
my viewers have become a breaking point
now I don't want you to write to me I
don't need you to write to me and say
not me David I'm still never voting for
Biden okay I'm not talking about you
what I'm telling you is that I have seen
nothing since the start of this election
that has triggered so many emails from
people saying I was not on board with
Biden for this reason or for that reason
but over the last three days I've
realized I have to vote for Biden in
November because this has gone too far
check out some of the tweets that were
sent to me here's one quote I despise
Biden and the Democrats still do but at
least he won't try to label millions of
our citizens as terrorists and SiC the
military on us I will crawl over broken
glass to vote for him in the fall
another tweet quote I've been a Bernie
supporter before people knew he existed
yet I am vote blue to save America 2020
as a history professor I've seen this
before when you have a chance to halt
fascism you do it
then fight for a leftist push question
what will we do when Trump refuses to
leave the White House another tweet
saying quote same here
that press conference BS was the nail in
the coffin so listen this is logical we
are now seeing this nascent
authoritarianism come full circle and I
want to add something that somebody
tweeted to me that I believe is very
important in the context of this
conversation I got a tweet which said
quote they need to be encouraged and not
shamed
and that is exactly right we were never
going to shame people out of sitting
aside in November it wasn't going to
work I've been talking about the the
futility of voter shaming for several
weeks if not months now and I'm not
going to shame them now I I have no
interest in doing this I told you so
stuff with the never Biden folks who are
realizing this is a crisis and we've got
to remove Trump what I'm gonna say is
I'm thrilled I'm thrilled and I knew you
would come around you are seeing the
reality of the situation for what it is
let's get together and defeat Donald
Trump I'm glad to have you no shame here
no I told you so here none of this stuff
I encourage everybody to do the exact
same thing I know yeah you know the
YouTube comments people will say David
you're so stupid I'm stung always never
Biden I'm not talking about you and we
don't need everyone we just need some
people to realize staying home is not
okay and right now this we we need to
remove Donald Trump if the last 72 hours
haven't made that sickeningly clear then
I don't know that there's anything left
that would convince you and in fact I
think again without shame with total
peace and love and curiosity I would go
back to the folks that are still never
Biden and say I want to engage with you
now that Donald Trump has continued the
satori authoritarian slide what else do
you need to say I've got to do it I've
got to vote for Biden is it some
specific policy position is there
anything Trump could do that would get
you to say okay now he's clearly bad
enough that I'm going to vote for Biden
rather than staying home or voting third
party or whatever I want to hear from
you and I hope that you will let me know